Speaker 1: But a major story, which we are
going to continue following another major
story this weekend of huge geopolitical and
foreign policy importance is that long time
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
of the Likud Party is finally out as prime
minister, replaced by the incoming prime minister,
Naftali Bennett. In Israel. Much of what takes
place is coalition based. And so what we have
seen here is that by a single vote margin,
Naftali Bennett is in and Benjamin Netanyahu
is out because of the coalition that Bennett
was able to form. The New York Times reports
the long and divisive reign of Benjamin Netanyahu,
the dominant Israeli politician of the past
generation, officially ended on Sunday, at
least for the time being, as the country's
parliament gave its vote of confidence to
a precarious coalition government stitched
together by widely disparate anti Netanyahu
forces Israelis. Israel's parliament, the
Knesset, approved the new government by just
a single vote 60 to 59, with one abstention
after his supporters cheered the announcement
of his election. Naftali Bennett then exchanged
a brief handshake with Netanyahu before walking
to the rostrum at the front of the parliamentary
chamber and taking the oath of office as Prime
Minister Yair Lapid, a centrist leader, is
set to take Mr. Bennett's place after two
years. If their government can hold together
that long, they lead an eight party alliance
ranging from left to right, from secular to
religious, that agrees on little but a desire
to oust Netanyahu, the longest serving leader
in the country's history and to end Israel's
lengthy political gridlock. In a speech made
before the confidence vote, Bennett hailed
his unlikely coalition as an essential antidote
to an intractable stalemate. We stopped the
train before the abyss, Bennett said. The
time has come for different leaders from all
parts of the people to stop to stop this madness.
Now you will remember that Netanyahu, as the
article points out, and his right wing allies
from Likud and other far right parties did
everything they could. I I mean, I guess maybe
there was something else they could have done,
something illegal. I don't know. They did
almost everything they could. They applied
pressure on other right wing opposition lawmakers.
They were trying to peel them away from possibly
being on the Bennett side, but ultimately
unable to do it. The question, of course,
now is what happens next? It's important to
understand that while Naftali Bennett is not
a Likud Knick, the party Likud of Benjamin
Netanyahu, there is this political alliance,
Yamina, which is an alliance of right wing
parties, including what was originally the
new right and some other parties. And we will
see ultimately how it shakes out in practice.
Now, it is still a right wing coalition and
it is still Naftali Bennett is still a right
winger. And it is a real question mark as
to as to what progress if. And he will be
able to be made in terms of the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict now on the other side, as I said
before, it is a requirement, but it is necessary
but not sufficient to remove Benjamin Netanyahu,
is there? If there is going to be any serious
chance that peace talks that could be productive
and and permanent or semi-permanent, as we
may call it, on the other side of that, Hamas,
we know simply cannot be, will not be. They
refused to be. There is no way that Hamas
will be a party to any kind of serious peace
talks. And Hamas seems potentially as ingrained
as ever in Gaza. Hamas, if you want to understand
sort of the outrageous dynamics of what's
going on there, Hamas recently awarded Al-Jazeera
an award which Al-Jazeera gladly accepted
for their coverage of the recent conflict
there. And for anybody who has legitimate
criticism of the way that the recent flare
up with Gaza was covered by certain media
outlets, but does not have concerns about
the coverage of, for example, Al-Jazeera,
which was recently given an award by Hamas.
You're sort of missing half of the picture.
So I remain extremely skeptical as to the
progress that will be made in the next two
years, serious progress when it comes to the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict. But removing
Benjamin Netanyahu as prime minister was step
zero, point one. It was a necessary step.
It is not sufficient. And we will now see
what happens next. It would be amazing if
there were able to be at least some initial
hypothetical guidelines set out for some kind
of serious path forward. But something that's
important to understand is, you know, one
of the risks of. Casually following the internal
politics of other countries is no matter who
you follow, like whether you're following
The New York Times and The Times of Israel
or whether you're following Al Jazeera for
your understanding of the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict, you sometimes miss the forest for
the trees. And one of the things that is really
important to understand is that within Israel,
meaning to Israelis, the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict does not actually rank particularly
high in terms of the concerns that the Israeli
people have for what they want a prime minister
or the new prime minister to focus on. It's
mostly internal issues. It's internal issues
related to economics, its internal issues
related to education and social services and
infrastructure, much like in the United States.
And it's not different in that sense. And
this is something that is really missed when
you look at Israel and the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict through any kind of Western media,
whether it's hard right. Or whether it's hard
left or whether it's centrist, our lens tends
to be foreign policy of Israel and the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict, much like in the United States foreign
policy. We listen in the middle of a completely
hairbrained war with Iraq. In 2004, George
W. Bush still was reelected. And the war in
Iraq, which is like we went to war with the
wrong country over a lie about the connection
between Saddam and 9/11, that's insane. And
even that only got the war in Iraq to a reasonably
important issue for Americans. The primary
issues were still domestic, economic, etc.
It's no different than Israel. And I think
that that's a really important detail to understand,
as anybody from outside of Israel tries to
follow and understand what it is that's going
on there. So Netanyahu out. That's the good
news. Below that, a whole bunch of other details
that raised questions that have not yet been
answered. Send me your thoughts about what
you expect, if anything, to change with the
removal of Benjamin Netanyahu. You can find
me on Twitter at David Pakman. We will take
a break. What a packed show today. It's really
a big one. Remember that The David Pakman
Show is primarily funded by individual members
like you, you can sign up today at Join Pakman
Dotcom and get instant access to so many great
things, including the Daily Bonus Show. You
can hear my crazy trip story, sort of, I guess,
on the Friday bonus show from last week. I
got a ton of responses to it and people found
it entertaining and sort of horrifying. But
my my trip story is on last Friday's bonus
show, sign up at Join Pakman dot com coupon
code is available better. Twenty one.